>> Welcome to Authors@Google and MarketingTalks@Google.
Today, we're proud to present Dave Murray.
He is a scientist and entrepreneur and all
around a pretty cool guy who's come to share
his insights. In the past, he's worked in
marketing. He has worked as a rocket scientist
and he's been the head of--innovation, excuse
me, at Intuit. So, I'm proud to present David
Murray and his book: Borrowing Brilliance.
>> MURRAY: Thank you. Thanks. It's good to
be here. There were two questions that I asked
myself that led to the writing of this book.
The first question was "Can you teach creativity?"
The second question was "Is innovation a definable
process?" And the answers to those questions
were "Yeah, I actually believe that you can
teach creativity" and the answer to the second
question is "Maybe as far as innovation being
a definable process." So, what I'd like to
talk you about is about answering those two
questions maybe teach you a little bit about
what I learned about creative thinking, I
mean, then, how you can apply it in your business.
The title of the book is Borrowing Brilliance.
And I named it that because I wanted the title
to reflect the primary premise of the book.
And what I did is like Effie [ph] said that
I was the head of innovation at Intuit and
it was in that job that I first started thinking
about creative thinking as a subject itself
and it's kind of a strange subject. So, what
I did is I started studying creative thinkers,
creative processes. But most importantly,
what I did is I studied creative ideas themselves,
and I asked myself, "You know, what makes
a creative idea? What – how do you construct
a creative idea?" And in that course, you
know, I studied scientific ideas. I mean,
I looked at Einstein and Darwin and Newton.
I studied business people: Bill Gates, Steve
Jobs, the Google guys. And in that process
of looking at that, I realized that creative
ideas are made out of existing ideas, always.
I mean, I could always, as you dug deeper
in you could always see the roots of an original
idea and an existing idea and that's why I
say that brilliance is borrowed. I think it's
why Einstein said, "The secret to creativity
is knowing how to hide your sources." So,
I was at--like I said, at the time I was working
at Intuit, so, Intuit was run by GE people.
GE people were process people. So, they were
like, "Dave, you've got to make a process
out of this." But I'm not sure it really was
a process, you know, and I'm not sure that
creative thinking, you can actually define
it in this series of steps, but I took that
challenge and I started thinking about it.
And these are what I came up with; these were
the six--when I called the six steps to innovation.
And I think about them, I break them into
separate parts and I think of two different
metaphors to describe them; the first one
being the origin of an idea. An idea is like
constructing a house, that's kind of a metaphor
that I use to think about that. The second
part is the evolution of a creative idea and
I have to separate them and I had to have
two different metaphors because the first
metaphor which is, which I thought it was
very powerful to the origin of an idea, the
construction metaphor, doesn't extend to the
process itself, because the process is a trial-and–error
process. So, that's why I switched metaphors
and the book is actually broken into two separate
sections. So, let's talk about the origin
of an idea and those three steps. And again,
it's a construction metaphor that I use and
I think it's very helpful to think about it
this way. The problem is the foundation of
that house. You build your ideas on a well-defined
problem. Borrowing then provides the materials
to build the solution to your problem. And
then you take the pieces and you make something
new out of them, you combine, you combine
the materials that you've grabbed. Let me
give you an example, I don't know if we have
any engineers in the house, but Isaac Newton
dabbled in Mathematics and he created Calculus,
and what he did is first he defined the problem.
He actually defined two problems. Does anybody
remember what those problems are? It was--no?
The area under a curve and the tangent to
a curve. And then he went out and he borrowed
some materials to solve that problem. In this
case, he borrowed--he went to Algebra, Trig,
Analytical Geometry and Infinitesimals, and
he combined that stuff in a unique way that
nobody else had done and created a solution
to the problems that he had defined, and that's
how he created the Calculus. And there's an
interesting side note about that; Isaac Newton
was, after he came out with Calculus, he was
accused of plagiarism, which isn't unusual
for creative thinkers. And he actually had
to defend himself in a court of law because
somebody else in another part of the world
had created Calculus at the same time. And
it was during his defense that Isaac Newton
said, "Yes, if I've seen farther, I've stood
on the shoulders of giants." And when he was
talking about the shoulders that he was standing
on were the creators of Algebra, Trigonometry,
Infinitesimals. So, I think it works in both
very complex idea creations like Calculus,
Physics, scientific, a lot of the problems
that you, guys, work on and it in works in
very simple problems too, very simple business
problems, marketing problems. The second part
of innovation and creativity is the evolution
of ideas. Ideas need time to evolve. I break
this into four steps, I mean, three steps.
There is incubation, that's where the subconscious
mind--the subconscious mind, all creative
thinkers are subconscious thinkers. The subconscious
is really good of doing the first three steps,
at defining, borrowing, combining and that's
kind of what's going on. You need to put your
ideas away, let them incubate. Then, you need
to pass judgment on your ideas. You know,
I don't know if you guys have a formal brain
storming process here at Google but, my experience
is that brainstorming such as don't work so
good because they lack judgment, and you need
strong judgment of an idea to figure out what's
wrong with an idea so you can evolve it. Judgment
is like, you know, it's like the fight for
survival in Darwin's theory of evolution.
And then finally, the sixth step is the enhancement
step, and that's trial and error, just keep
doing it over and over and sometimes it's
just restructuring the materials that you
have. In 1820, Hans Austred [ph], he did an
experiment and he noticed that with wires,
magnets and a compass, and he noticed that
when he passed a current through the comp--when
you pass the current through the wire, the
compass went, went haywire. He created a magnetic
field, that was an interesting idea, but 20
years later Michael Faraday took that idea
and restructured it and when he did is he
passed the magnets around the wire and created
the current. Now, that was a huge innovation,
I mean that's how power plants work now like
in a hydroelect--in a hydroelectric plant.
A turbine spins magnets around the wire and
that's how it creates current. The point being
is when you get to that last step, sometimes
you just take the materials that you have
restructure them, move them around. So, I
was just thinking—sorry, I lost that. Give
me just a second you, guys, I'm sorry. Let's
take in and talk about the six steps in a
more depth. There's the problem step. You
know, my experience is that were we have a
lot--we're very good at solving problems but
we're not necessarily very good at defining
problems, and there's three parts to, or to,
to the problem step. There's the identification
of a problem. There's the understanding of
the problem which is finding out the root
cause, and then, the third one is describing
the problem, and sometimes it's just changing
the description of the problem a little bit
that will lead to in innovation. Let me give
you an example, I was working with the Fortune
500 company and the CEO called me in and there
was a marketing group and he's like, "You
know, I keep giving these guys the same problem
and they keep coming back with the same answer.
We need to get them, you know, we need to
get innovations out of there" and I was like
"What we really need to do is change the problem."
Henry Ford, back in the 1920s, he had, he
defined his problem as building the least
expensive car and he was very successful with
it, and all of his ideas were built off building
the least expensive car. William Durant over
General Motors then took that problem and
kind of redefined it just a little bit. He
said, "Let's build a car that people can afford"
and that just by, just by changing the, the
definition of the problem just a little bit
led to a huge innovation which was GMAC. And
so what they did is they solved the problem,
they built more expensive cars but people
can afford them through monthly payments.
The--so when I work with a conceptual development
team, what you guys need to do is keep going
back to that problem and keep trying, just
subtle differences and how you define it,
it can change how you solve it. The next step
is the borrowing step, and this is where you
gather the materials. And I think of this--imagine
thinking the--of this as on a continuum and
what you want to do is the way that you define
the problem will determine where you look
for your solution, and this works, again,
in both a simple--in both simple problems
and complex problems. You know, for example,
my daughter is studying fashion right now,
so she bought a book on Coco Chanel, and Coco
Chanel was--she was named one of the Time
magazine--excuse me--one of the most influential
people of the, of the 20th century, and what
she did is she defined the problem. She wanted
to liberate women and that was the problem
that she defined. And when she defined it,
she, she said, "Okay, if I'm going to liberate
women, where am I going to look for solutions?"
and where she looked was men's clothing. So
she combined men's clothing with women's clothing
and that solved her problem.
John Nash, the economist from the movie A
Beautiful Mind. You know, he--well, the way
that he developed his ideas is he, he defined
the problem and then went to--he didn't noticed
that the problem--and his problem was the
looking at or making decisions with incomplete
information and he--he noticed that; well,
that's the same problem that people that have
in a poker game. So what he did is he borrowed
poker game strategies and solved economic--he
solved economic problems with that. So, what
I--what I like to teach is, when you're solving
your problems, first, what you do is you start
close to home. If you're a software engineer
and you've got a navigation problem, then
I would look at how other software engineers
solve that navigation problem. Then, I would
take this a step away, and I would look at
maybe web designers, how do they solve that
problem? And I'll borrow ideas from there
and then I would take a step outside of business.
How do sailors, truck drivers, search and
rescue teams--how do they solve their navigation
problems, and then combine all that. And,
again, that leads to the third step which
is the combination step. You take all these
materials and then you combine them to form
a new solution.
Combination is really the essence of creativity.
You know, it's taking two existing things
and making a new thing. It's funny, and this
was a big "aha" moment for me as I was thinking
about this and thinking about creative thinking.
And I was like, you know, is it really that
simple, is creativity, is it--is it a new
idea or just two existing ideas and I think
it is, and I sort of thinking about that.
And as--I was in a meeting, actually, at Intuit
and across from the table was sitting a friend
of mine, and I guess I kept glancing at her,
and staring at her. Subconsciously, I didn't
realize it until she kind of mouthed the words,
"What the hell are you looking at?" And, then
I've realized why I was staring at her, because
I kept asking myself the question--well, actually,
let me take a step back--I was asking myself
the question, what is the most important or
the biggest idea in the history of the human
race? You know and I was thinking is it Einstein's
idea, is it Darwin's, is it--I don't know,
is it Star Wars. And that's when I started
glancing at my friend, and then I realized
why I was staring at her, because she was
pregnant. And I went, "aha," I go, that's
the answer to the question, that's probably
the most creative thing, the most important
idea, is a new human being. And what is a
new human being? It's a combination of two
existing human beings. The fifth step--or,
I'm sorry, the fourth step is incubation,
that's when you bring the subconscious mind
into it. And, I think the--you need to--most
creative, or all creative thinkers have a
very strong relationship to the subconscious
mind. And I work hard with myself to try to
establish that relationship, and I do three
things, and I think about it three ways. It's
input to the subconscious mind, so that's
when I tell my subconscious, "Okay these are--this
is my problem, these are some of the borrowings
that I have, and then here's some interesting
unique combinations." The--and then, I just
put it away and give it time. The subconscious
mind is kind of like a parallel processing
computer, and it can make all these combinations
behind the scene. The third part, and this
is probably the most critical part, and maybe
the hardest part, and that's output; listening
to the subconscious mind. You know, as I discuss
this with a lot of people, and does everybody
have the shower experience, the "aha" moment
in the shower? And I wondered that's kind
of weird that everyone is having that same
experience. And then I realized why, the subcon--I
mean, the morning shower is one of the few
times of the day when your conscious mind
isn't like aflutter with information. You're
kind of relax, it's in the morning, so, in
other words, you're not thinking at all and
that gives the subconscious time to have something
to say. The ideas pop in, and I think that's
why the ideas keep popping in, and the book
I talk about, how you can kind of simulate
that shower experience. The fifth step is
the judging step. Judgment is so critical
because without it, your ideas are going to
be frivolous and useless. I think I--what
I do is, is I separate my judgment into two,
maybe three areas, but two primary areas:
the positive judgment and negative judgment,
and I use the problem as a criterion. And,
I think it's not judgment of whether you like
the idea or not, it's judgment, what do I
like about the idea and what don't I like
about the idea? And there's a magnificent
side effect that you get when you start doing
that, and it's creative intuition, because
what you get, as you start--as these ideas
start flowing and you start passing judgment,
positive and negative, you start being able
to describe an idea that doesn't exist. It
has these attributes from your positive judgments
and it doesn't have this other attributes
from your negatives. Steve Jobs, who--if anything
that--or probably his greatest creative attribute
is his creative intuition. He knows a good
idea when he sees it. And, he's also notorious
for having a contra--a contrary personality,
in other words, he's really positive one moment,
and really negative the next moment, and I
think that's what gives him the creative intuition.
He's able to say, "I really like these points,
and I really don't like those points." Now,
you and I are never going to be Steve Jobs.
I think it's innate in his thinking, but if
you start doing it consciously, making those
two different positives and negatives, you'll
start to develop it too and then, as you're
going through like your work and stuff, you'll
see an idea and you'll be like, oh, my God
that's the idea that I was looking for. And
then finally, there's enhancement, the enhancement
step. The creative process is a trial and
error process, and ideas need to evolve, products
need to evolve, you know. In the enhancement
process you're basically going back and you've
redefined your problem, you re-borrow materials,
you re-combine and re-structure and you come
up with the next iteration of the idea. And
I think Facebook is probably a good example.
Facebook started out--the original conception
of Facebook was basically borrowing the Hot
or Not site, at, Mark Zuckerberg was a freshman
at Harvard University and he started the Hot
or Not site, where you would rank the incoming
Harvard freshman. He borrowed the name Facebook
from--that's what they called, they actually
printed a yearbook where you can look at the
faces of the incoming freshman. And now, but
if you look at the evolution--so that's where
they started with the idea, and now they're
like, you know, 250 million users; they've
just passed MySpace. They just keep evolving,
they keep working it, they keep redefining,
keep restructuring their problems and their
solutions to the problems. So, there is--you
know—any, yeah, any questions? You know,
I think, we've got some books in the back,
I'd appreciate anybody would like to buy--oh,
you have a question...
>> All right. Well...
>> MURRAY: Okay.
>> Well, first of all, thank you very much
for spending with us today; it's a very, very
awesome talk. I'm in, in the creativity research
and the literature, you know, the two big
questions that that come to my mind or like,
first, how you can sort of, you know, create--creativity
like I envision somebody telling me, like,
be creative and then that's kind of difficult.
And then also, I was wondering if you could
comment on the role between, you know, similarly
between creativity and control. Like how,
how, you know, how like, how it should ramp
in instead of like instead of blue sky in
order to make forward progress?
>> MURRAY: Right.
>> Thanks.
>> MURRAY: Well, yeah and that's an interesting
point. I think there was a paradoxical intention
to creativity. That thing were, you know,
do it and then, I think, that's because we
use our subconscious minds to come up with
ideas. And when you demand something from
your subconscious mind, it'll tend to like,
you know, shut you off. The way that I think
that you come over that is you start doing
things consciously. In other words, when you
can't come up with an idea, you go back and
you say, okay, what problem am I working on?
All right. There is a problem. Okay. What
materials do I have to--and you start doing
it consciously, and then your subconscious
then will pick up on it, does that makes sense?
Okay.
>> So, again, thank you so much for coming.
Another question for you--when you've mentioned
these different areas that people have borrowed
from, they tend to be--well, they somehow
seem very different from the area in which
they're trying to solve the problem. Like,
the poker, example, can you talk a little
bit about tips perhaps to get people thinking
in sort of broader ways without just going,
again, off the deep end.
>> MURRAY: Yeah, yeah. I mean, I think, it
all comes back to the problem. You define
the problem and then you look for places with
the similar problem. The reason John Nash
went to the poker game is because he recognized
that poker players were making decisions with
the incomplete information. And he's like,
wait a minute, that's the same, that's the
same problem that people in the economy have,
and once he recognized the same problem then
he was able to borrow from it. So that's,
I think, the key to it is how you define a
problem and then you go to places, and actually
think of it on the continuum, I start this
at home then I do something similar and then
I look really far away. So, you know, if I'm,
if I'm a business person, I'm looking to science.
How does scientist solve a problem like this,
and then I borrow ideas from there. You know
if I'm a scientist, I might look to business,
say how they solve it and kind of swap it
out.
>> Hey.
>> MURRAY: Yeah.
>> Thank you as well. Kind of a related question...
>> I remember BMW or like other car manufacturers
looking at biology and nature to improve their
products. For instance, wires for their tires,
they look at, you know, frogs' hands and see
why, why are they sticking so well to, to
objects? If I think now, I mean, I'm working
in marketing and if I would think to looking
at, you know, the nature or problems in the
nature, it's such a huge area, how would you
define the, I mean, the process or some kind
of, of way of approaching such a broad area
to improve your own problems to work on it?
>> MURRAY: Right, right. And I think the answer
to that question is, again, it comes back
to the problem. There's a whole branch of
engineering called bionics, and they look
at, you know, I think, I think, people studied
the lotus flower because it repels water,
so then with sci--what the scientists, what
the business people did was they said, what's
going on there? And, took ideas from that
and created products out of it. So, again,
it really comes back to, this all comes back
to the problem. How you define it will determine
where you look, does that make sense? It's
just not random places out there that you
borrow. You borrow from similar places with
the same problem.
>> Thank you for the talk; extremely interesting.
So, your slides relates to an individual.
It's supposed to process...
>> MURRAY: Yeah.
>> You know like in, in going in a creative
direction, put it that way. But, could you
expand a little bit, you know, like, you know,
in a typical corporate setup. How would each
one of these steps...
>> MURRAY: Yeah.
>> Be supported by say, a larger organization?
>> MURRAY: Right.
>> Could you give in like, what do you need
to do, what do you need to put in place for
individuals to actually be able to sort of
have less friction in going through these
six steps?
>> MURRAY: Yeah, yeah. So, let me make a couple,
a response to that in a couple ways. So I
believe the creative process does take place
in your mind. The ideas are going to come
from your mind and that's really what my book
is about. It's--the book is a personal book
and I tell personal stories and I get into
my own mind. Now with that said, understanding
the creative process and how it works does
translate into how you would create processes
at your company. So, for example, I would
separate these, I mean, I would, when I brainstorm
or when I'm in a concept development team,
we will separate and we'll just work on the
problem, and we won't brainstorm, we won't
talk anything about solutions, it's just pure,
okay, defining problems and a hierarchy of
problems. I mean, problems don't exist in
isolation. There's high problems, low problems,
there's a whole bunch--you have internal problems,
external problems so, I'd separate that. I'd
look at the problems, then I would do another
meeting where I'd like, okay, I've picked
out a couple problems and it say, let's send
everybody out and find places outside of our
business that are solving these kind of problems,
and we would send like the whole organization
out to look at that. People would come back
in and then present back here's, so they,
you know, we would do the second step. Now,
then, we would do brainstorming, and then
maybe even in a separate meeting, we would
do judgment where we'd bring in some, you
know, usually the top, the top managers are
usually really good at judgment, at telling
you why your idea doesn't work, and telling
you why your idea might work. So, you know,
the incubation thing, that is, that's a real
personal thing, but it also means that, you
know what, we have to understand that our
ideas are going to take a little bit of time,
we need to work on them a little bit, so.
Any other questions? Cool. Well, thank you,
guys.